immer mehr menschen zieht es in die
städte und das stellt stadtplaner vor
große herausforderungen
wir sind eine wachsende stadt das heißt
es gibt immer mehr einwohner immer mehr
verkehr immer mehr infrastruktur
notwendig ist
neue ideen sollen der stadt leben besser
machen und nachhaltiger
wir verbessern den öffentlichen verkehr
damit menschen besucht wird wie
intelligente smart city zeichnet sich
durch neue technologien und einfacher
geniale lösung aus wie können die städte
von heute zu lebenswerten orten der
zukunft werden
[Musik]
da vorne haben wir unsere ersten
sensoren verbaut die messen jetzt hier
lärmpegel und den co2 gehalt in der luft
und als nächstes möchten wir auch den
straßenzustand erfassen
das heißt wie ist es mit eisglätte wie
ist es mit regen wie es generell mit
schnee dass wir auch darüber
informationen haben rossy david der
tore- suárez will darmstadt in die
zukunft führen mit sensoren die gibt es
jetzt überall in der stadt
der 31 jährige ist geschäftsführer der
digital stadt darmstadt
er sucht die balance zwischen heute und
morgen zwischen hightech und historische
wir wollen nicht anstatt haben die so
technologisierten ist dass man den
eindruck hat das ist nicht mehr das
darmstadt was man kennt
wir sind stolz auf den charakter dieser
stadt auch auf das jugendstil auf die
kultur die hier haben und wir möchten
dass erhalten auch im kontext der spot
city darmstadt gewann 2017 einen
wettbewerb und damit reichlich
fördergelder und darf sich jetzt digital
stadt nennen
in den nächsten jahren ist die
südhessische stadt rasant gewachsen auf
über 160.000 einwohner hinzu kommen
täglich etwa 126.000 händler
[Musik]
das bedeutet viel verkehr doch darmstadt
ist ein vorreiter in sachen
stauvermeidung dank eines marken
ampelsystems
diplom ingenieur ralf tanke ist mit nur
einem weiteren kollegen für die gesamte
ampelschaltung der stadt verantwortlich
technik was für ein unterschied es ist
was früher per hand erledigt wurde
übernehmen jetzt sensoren und kameras
ampeln erfassen autos und radfahrer in
echtzeit telefon auto ich fahre auch
gerne auto und man spürt es morgens ist
viel verkehr los in der stadt man steht
an gewissen stellen auch das beispiel
können sie haben sie hinter sich das
bild zum beispiel von einer anlage wo
wir den verkehr fassen
sowohl für uns ist es nur wichtig wenn
sie da diese weißen carlo sehen immer
wenn das feld weiß es wird ein fahrzeug
detektiert das ist einzig etwas bei uns
in die datenbank in echtzeit eingeht
im sekundentakt kommen die daten bei
ralf tankan flexible ampel programme
sorgen für den bestmöglichen fluss der
pendler massen nicht nur im
berufsverkehr auch in ausnahmefällen
kann fußball spielen sollen das kann die
baustelle sein und mithalten kann dieses
system automatisch diese eigenes
delektieren tagesaktuell verkehr und
dann haben wir nicht ein abendprogramm
was halt eine geringe leistungsfähigkeit
sondern wir könnten automatisch dann
ereignis in der länge und sank dann
schalte und leistungsfähiges programm da
kann der verkehr zu diesem zweiten
presse fließen da war man doch dann
stadt will nicht allein die autos besser
steuern
auch der öffentliche nahverkehr soll und
muss gestärkt werden
carsharing bus und bahn eine lösung gibt
es schon eine app sammelt alle
verkehrsinfos der stadt
ich gebe jetzt ein die haltestelle zu
erfahren wollen sucht haben wir die
verbindung raus und ich kann dann in der
app sehen ob die straßen waren jetzt
kommen und kann auch in echtzeit
nachverfolgt wo sie genau gerade ist und
auf der karte kann nicht aussehen wo ist
das nächste carsharing-angebot das
nächste beispiel angebot und sucht das
meer aus in der nächsten schritt ist
dass ich direkt in der verbindung alles
kaufen kann
die heraussuchen kann und auch sehe wie
viel schneller bin ich vielleicht zum
auto davor srs sieht in der
digitalisierung eine riesenchance
ganze 14 bereiche der stadt sollen smart
werden neben mobilität auch die
verwaltung energie und die umwelt ich
möchte schaffen dass wir den großen
nutzen im alltag das information und es
ist lebenswert lösungen für die bürger
da tor des jahres will die darmstädter
deshalb von seinem vorhaben überzeugen
die zukunft der stadt als bürger event
wenn wir wirklich von den bürgern sehr
gute anregungen bekommen sie wirklich
sehen was ihr projekt wir haben sich
einbringen dass wir und holzen darmstadt
ist auf dem weg in die zukunft wie viel
überzeugungsarbeit ist dafür wohl
notwendig woanders ist man schon fast
angekommen
helsinki die finnische hauptstadt
verwandelt ihren alten fischereihafen
calafat aber in ein smartes wohnquartier
es ist eine probebühne für das leben von
morgen mitten drin lebt johan harju mit
seiner familie ist ein brot gekostet
also das ist meine rolle ich renne herum
und bin der der das brot serviert
[Musik]
seit fünf jahren lebt die familie in
kanazawa
der unternehmensberater ist heute morgen
mit der kinderbetreuung dran
die mutter arbeitet schon damit alles
reibungslos klappt nutzt johanna die app
der grundschule
[Musik]
das ist führt euro du siehst die schule
fängt heute um 9 mit englisch an
und ich kann sehen welche fächer sie
noch habe ich kann fragen hast du dein
englisch buch dabei das ist echt
hilfreich hier ist eine nachricht des
schulleiterin ich kann ihr damit direkt
antworten
er steht alles drin ganz einfach
intelligente details erleichtern den
familienalltag in ganz vielen bereichen
auch bei der entsorgung des mülls
denn der verschwindet im viertel in
einem unterirdischen system hier ist
unser smartes müllsystem die druckluft
kommt von da leute den müll den ganzen
weg raus aus dem feld ich eröffne die
klappe werfe den müll rein ganz sauber
es stinkt nicht
auch der biomilch schnell sauber und
kompliziert der müll ist entsorgt für
die familie geht es weiter zur schule
und der eingeworfenen müll beginnt eine
reise unter der stadt
denn im smarten viertel von callas obama
sucht man stinkenden müllwagen
vergeblich der abfall wird über rühren
an den stadtrand geleitet und von dort
abtransportiert
die rohre kommen von jedem block mit
druckluft in diese sammelstation
stadtplaner thomas hacker ist das
superhirn hinter dem müll systemen und
dem ganzen modernen stadtteil damit es
sich lohnt braucht das system viele
nutzer bei 25.000 bewohnern in kall
assad aber lohnt es braucht diese dichte
weil der baubeginn auf
auch die überirdische nachbarschaft der
zukunft hat der architekt und stadt
erneuerer geplant helsinkis höchstes
gebäude soll hier entstehen denn die
stadtbevölkerung wächst rasant und auch
helsinki kommt mit dem wohnungsbau kaum
hinterher
wir fahren in den sechzehnten stock da
sind schon fenster drin
das gebäude wird nicht nur das höchste
sondern auch das intelligenteste der
stadt nidda werden jederzeit über ihren
energieverbrauch informiert die
wohnräume lassen sich flexibel aufteilen
was entsteht hier ein balkon
genau ein mix aus wintergarten und
balkon
und hier ist dann die flexible wand in
den nächsten jahren entstehen hier 1500
apartments architekt hacker konnte sich
bei seiner planung des viertels am
reißbrett richtig austoben
manchmal war das gar nicht so leicht
[Musik]
wenn man auf eine bestehende stadt
struktur aufbaut bedeutet dass grenzen
aber auch einen wenn ich von grund auf
anfang ist das einfach weil ich keinen
bestehenden elementen folgen aber es ist
auch schwierig die schwierigkeiten hat
thomas hacker la gemeistert und im neuen
viertel vieles weitergedacht in der
smart city von kallas hat aber zu leben
heißt kurze wege in die natur optimale
verkehrsanbindung selbst fahrende busse
arbeitsplätze und schulen direkt im
viertel helsinki probt das leben von
morgen mit unterirdischem abfallsystem
einem sparsamen strom und wärme netz und
intelligenten häusern
planer haag allah will aber keine noble
hafencity sondern einen ort für alle
gesellschaftlichen schichten oberstes
ziel eine gute soziale mischung in
diesem bereich sind reihenhäuser 200
quadratmeter große eigentumswohnungen
und direkt gegenüber sozialbau für
behinderte thomas hacker ist stolz auf
dieses prinzip
[Musik]
man soll nicht schon an der fassade
erkennen was eigentum mietwohnung oder
preisregulierten die sogenannte
großvater brücke ist ihm besonders
wichtig sie führt die bewohner direkt in
die umliegende natur alles hier ist zum
vorteil der menschen gedacht
wir wollen den menschen eine stunde
freizeit am tag schenken wir binden das
gebiet perfekt an
alles ist in nächster nähe
es ist einfach zur arbeit zum einkaufen
in die natur zukunft so gewinnen die
menschen zeit
intelligente städte zum wohle der
menschen kann das überall gelingen
[Musik]
vitoria gastes im spanischen baskenland
was braucht eine stadt mit
mittelalterlichen stadtkern ums markt zu
werden erst einmal bauarbeiten hier
sogar jahrelang wir haben die zeit
ausgehalten aber andere geschäfte
mussten zu machen aber gut zum glück
haben sich die bauarbeiten gelohnt ich
glaube dass alle davon profitieren und
jetzt haben wir hier eine schöne straße
der wirt hat seine bar gleich neben dem
historischen stadtkern frühjahr führte
hier eine hauptstraße lang in die zeit
vergangen ist unglaublich er ist über
die vier fahrspuren meine güte
[Musik]
victoria hatte ein problem zu viel
verkehr verstopfte straßen schlechte
luft vor zehn jahren machte sich juan
carlos escudero daran das zu ändern
der barbesitzer ist heute dankbar dafür
er profitiert vom umbau und mehr
fußgänger bringen mehr laufkundschaft
früher sah es so aus eine betonwüste
lärm abgase seit damals hat juan carlos
ganze straßenzüge komplett ungeplant es
gibt neue fahrradwege eine tram
grünflächen
die autos mussten weichen der mensch
rückte in den mittelpunkt jetzt wird der
verkehr geschickt um die innenstadt
herum geleitet
vor zehn jahren war es ganz normal
hinter sich eine hupe zu hören wenn man
mit dem fahrrad unterwegs war
der autofahrer der hinter einem war gab
damit zu verstehen dass man ihn
behindert heute kommt es kaum noch
seitdem werden in vitoria 42 prozent
weniger co2 ausgestoßen die
feinstaubbelastung ist um 38 prozent
gesunken und auch die neue begrünung
verbessert das stadtklima hilfe bekam
der stadtplaner von ressorts antonio
gonzalez
der landschaftsarchitekt hat das dach
des kongresszentrums in eine oase
verwandelt solche gärten sollen jetzt
überall in der stadt entstehen damit
auch die nachbarn zufrieden sind dass
sie jetzt einen schönen ausblick haben
die pflanzen verhindern an heißen
sommertagen dass sich die häuserfassaden
aufheizen und das absolut pflegeleicht
alle pflanzen hier brauchen ganz wenig
wasser sie können zwei monate ohne einen
tropfen regen überleben zur bewässerung
während des sommers haben wir eine
zisterne im keller
die fängt das regenwasser auf und damit
werden die pflanzen dann versorgt
das begrünte kongresszentrum mitten in
der stadt ist für von carlos vorbild für
weitere gebäude auch historische städte
wie vitoria können fit werden für die
zukunft
[Musik]
die innenstadt gehört jetzt den
radfahrern und fußgängern und weil die
stadt auf einem berg liegt wurden
einfache rolltreppen in die
fußgängerzone integriert so kann
wirklich jeder die steilen straßen
hochkommen
[Musik]
im letzten jahrhundert wurden alle
städte für autos geplant
nicht nur wie toll und autos haben den
großteil des öffentlichen raums
eingenommen
warum sollte man nicht das ziel haben
den großteil unserer städte den menschen
zurückzugeben
dafür werden in vitoria viele
alternativen angeboten
[Musik]
glücklicher weise entsteht jetzt an
verschiedenen orten der stadt ein
netzwerk von sicher über wachten
parkplätzen für fahrräder
das hat früher viele davon abgehalten
das fahrrad zu nehmen nicht zu wissen wo
man es sicher abstellen
doch alle diese veränderungen stoßen in
einer historischen stadt wie vitoria auf
bauliche grenzen und nicht jedem
gefallen sie auch nach dem bau einer
straßenbahn inmitten der stadt frag ich
mich ist das jetzt moderne oder eine
reise in die vergangenheit
nun wäre direkt an der straße man wohnt
leidet darunter die damit gut ins
zentrum kommen freunde mit seinen ideen
wird von carlos immer auf widerstände
stoßen der preis des 9
[Musik]
es ist schwer es allen recht zu machen
aber die mehrheit sieht es positiv ja
gut im bürgerdialog wird eben eher mal
kritisiert weniger gelobt so ist das mit
einer vision hat juan carlos die meisten
bürger aber bereits überzeugt der grüne
gürtel von vitoria das ace 7 127 hektar
pure natur fußläufig vor der stadt eine
fläche von 1000 fußballfeldern ein fast
80 kilometer langes wegenetz für durch
das biotop der ehemalige
militärflughafen ist aufwendig
umgestaltet worden in ein
erholungsgebiet für die stadtbewohner
[Musik]
zwischen den zwei bäumen siehst du und
das sind noch mehr direkt dahinter
hier liegt die grünen lunge der stadt
eine smart city zeichnet sich nicht nur
durch neue technologien aus sondern
durch manchmal einfache geniale lösungen
wie etwa unseren grüngürtel wir
unterstützen hier auch noch die natur
lösen damit größere alltagsproblem die
lösung für mehr lebensqualität ein ort
der erholung auch das ist smart im
mittelalterlichen vitoria wurde in zehn
jahren viel verändert in südhessen steht
darmstadt in den startlöchern
auch hier geht es um die vorteile für
die anwohner der digital berater da
torres ors will die bürger von darmstadt
zukunftsplänen überzeugen
die direkte bürgerbeteiligung ist teil
der smart city
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt schon neben 70
das ist
schwer das alles
nachzuvollziehen was da passiert haben
dann kommt auch kritische bürger werden
gehört schließlich gibt es in ihrer
stadt bei zahlreichen sensoren verfolgt
werden oder in ländern landen wo es ein
datenschutzgesetz das wm ist sehr
wichtig ansonsten ist das tätigkeitsfeld
was sinnvolles wird digitalisiert und
sehr groß dann soll auch das sinnvolle
gemacht digitalisierung soll in
darmstadt demokratisch sein zb für den
umweltbereich relevant wären
schadstoffmessung
irgendwie verschmutzungs zahlen
der belästigung blm lernen es ist ein
spagat zwischen den generationen und den
auffassungen aber notwendig wenn es den
größten nutzen für die mehrheit bringen
soll
das motiviert mich unheimlich die
gespräche der austausch die projekte die
wir umsetzen können die vernetzung in
der stadt es ist einfach wahnsinn
und so viele ideen die neu entstehen wo
man sagt lass es angehen und wehrdienst
auch an
und das motiviert mich bei einer idee
können bürger schon heute selbst aktiv
sein
mit der mängel melder app im
vorbeifahren hat felix zerfass gestern
abend eine defekte straßenlaterne
entdeckt
ich werde gleich ein foto von der
laterne machen und in der app dann das
foto hochladen und damit der stadt
darmstadt mitteilen quasi an welcher
stelle sie las americas
ein foto und eine kurze beschreibung das
war's
und jetzt
wird das hochgeladen meldung erfolgreich
erstellt und das war es auch schon der
bürgerhinweis landet direkt bei der
zuständigen stelle in diesem fall beim
örtlichen stromnetzbetreiber die meldung
enthält dem präzisen standort des
mangels so kann er schneller behoben
werden
ob defekte straßenlaternen wilde
sperrmüllhaufen oder schlaglöcher die
meldungen der bürger werden direkt
aufgenommen und bearbeitet bürger und
stadt arbeiten zusammen um probleme
schnell zu lösen
aber auch kleine dinge des alltags
können richtig sein
darmstadt ist dem bürger wunsch
nachgekommen auch mini beträge beim
bäcker oder metzger mit der ec karte zu
zahlen
das geht inzwischen schon bei mehreren
geschäften
ich freue mich auf das bargeld
mitzunehmen muss mir nicht gedanken
machen ob ich genug geld dabei habe
sondern kann es einfach nutzen und das
wollen wir weiter ausbauen und zwar
konkrete bürger idee die wir umgesetzt
haben die dort kam das ist einfach toll
also nicht noch bargeld zu suchen jetzt
zu benutzen sondern einfach mit der
karte hingegen bezahlen
es geht auch sehr schnell gerade bei den
kleinen beträgen das ist toll bürgernahe
lösungen das ist sein ziel für das
künftige darmstadt
der nächste termin führt ihn an den
stadtrand zu einer straßenlaterne aber
zu einer ganz besonderen einer mit
intelligenter licht schaltung ein sensor
kann bei der smart light ganz
automatisch störungen der lampe erkennen
und melden die laternen können aber noch
viel mehr intelligenz quasi die sensorik
für die leuchten mir dran haben hier
eine präsenz erfassung in der stellung
das heißt wenn fahrradfahrer oder
muskeln fußgänger hier den weg betreten
dann die beleuchtung hoch geregelt und
wenn sich dann hier keiner mehr befindet
dann wird die beleuchtung herunter
geregelt und das schont die umwelt spart
strom
es ist für uns tolles beispiel was
greifbar ist wo die leute also aus dem
alltag wir haben hier viele fußgänger
fahrradfahrer auch schulkinder die den
weg nutzen und gerade in der dunklen
jahreszeit wenn die dann merken auch ich
laufe jetzt vorbei das licht reagiert
auf mich ich bin persönlich das hat ein
ganz anderes
empfinden verein selbst nur dass so was
wirklich auf mich reagiert eingesetzt im
ganzen stadtgebiet könnten solche lampen
den energieverbrauch der stadt drastisch
senken
[Musik]
im hohen norden führt helsinki seine
bürger noch umfassender in neue zeiten
mehr lebensqualität mehr zeit neue
technik und kurze wege
[Musik]
es ist ein dorf in der stadt alles hier
ist zunächst vater johan harju bringt
seine kinder zur grundschule von callas
ataman
die ist von jeder wohnung des viertels
in maximal zehn minuten zu fuß
erreichbar und auch die schule ist
anders es ist ein pilotprojekt der stadt
das besondere lernen ohne tische diesen
anderen zu
es macht spaß hier es ist gleich der
zumindest gleich die schule im
modernsten stadtteil von helsinki setzt
auf offenheit die architektur hilft
dabei die klassenräume sind großzügig
gestaltet die kinder können sich frei
bewegen
babak isabel louis ist englisch lehrer
unterrichtet hier seit drei jahren
dies ist etwas schwieriger was heißt ich
habe spinnen auf englisch
sitzsäcke bewegung und offene räume der
lehrer ist überzeugt so sieht das lernen
von morgen aus ich habe die erfahrung
gemacht in diesem offenen raum befreit
es die schüler beim lernen ganz anders
als in einem stuhl festzustecken
sie können sich aussuchen wo sie sitzen
wollen auf dem boden einer bank einem
tisch es gibt ihnen mehr freiheit und
noch etwas ist hier besonders der
unterricht findet auch außerhalb der
schule statt
so wird das ganze viertel selbst zum
offenen klassenraum das was hier in cala
sa tama erprobt wird dient als blaupause
für weitere schulen der stadt
bis 2025 plant helsinki außerdem
autofrei zu werden
bis dahin sollen alle ziele der stadt
mit dem bus oder mit dem fahrrad zu
erreichen sein
im neuen stadtteil carlos santana wohnt
auch villen ozeanen er treibt die mobile
innovation der stadt mit voran
besonders in sachen mobilität ist mein
leben ziemlich smart
ich nutze jeden tag eine app für
leihräder günstige taxis mit war
wir teilen uns hier die verschiedenen
verkehrsmittel
der 28 jährige ist überzeugt ein eigenes
auto zu besitzen ist nicht mehr
zeitgemäß deswegen hat er ein besonderes
projekt mit aus der taufe gehoben
seit drei jahren arbeitet er an
autonomen verlosungen für helsinki die
zukunft soll dem robus gehören die
möglichkeiten dieser busse sind enorm
ich hoffe dass wir sie bis 2020 das
ganze jahr über einsetzen können so
verbessern wir die anbindungen für die
menschen und sie brauchen dann gar kein
eigenes auto mehr
obwohl wille auf die autonome technik
vertraut betreuen im moment noch
zusätzlich studenten die fahrten sollte
sich künstliche intelligenz mal irren
greifen sie ein
der elektrische busse erfasst mit laser
und radar geräten die strecke und bewegt
sich eigenständig im verkehr will glaubt
fest daran dass ist die zukunft des
stadtverkehrs
[Musik]
das läuft hier schon sehr gut wir fahren
schneller denn je 18 stundenkilometer
sind zwar langsam für normale autos aber
wenn man bedenkt dass wir bei zwölf
stundenkilometer angefangen haben der
bus hat einen fußgänger erkannt und
gebremst autonome busse sollen in kall
astana vor allem die kurzstrecken
abdecken
[Musik]
stadtplaner thomas hacker ist stolz auf
sein hafen viertel und auch auf die
kleinen smart details ich kann hier mein
handy aufladen ich muss den knopf
drücken und schon fängt an zu laden und
dann kann ich ganz in ruhe meinen kaffee
trinken eine öffentliche ladestation mit
solarzellen für thomas hacker zählte
aber vor allem das große ganze
seine arbeit für karl astana ist
größtenteils getan ist
das ist immer schön zu sehen
gestern habe ich etwas entworfen und
heute baut jemand wirklich die häuser
und straßen gute anbindungen kurze wege
helsinki hat errechnet dass die bewohner
durch die errungenschaften der smart
city bis zu einer stunde freie zeit
sparen können
johanna hey you ist dieser eine stunde
viel wert nach der arbeit nutzt er die
freie zeit am liebsten draußen sein
hohen viertel liegt naturnah dank
intelligenter planung sein lieblingsziel
die sommer sauna und abends auch mal
offline sein ist für ihn wichtig immer
zu sind wir online am computer oder dem
handy aber wenn dir das ausschalten
können und für eine stunde in der sauna
sitzen finde ich das mal dass laut einer
eigenen batterien auf und das ist das
allerwichtigste
die stadt der zukunft nachhaltig und
lebenswert und letztlich sind es nicht
die sensoren oder hightech die in das
smart city im mittelpunkt stehen sondern
die menschen die in ihr leben
[Musik]